on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored
coming up on tonight's program
as the pressure increases over Rashid
sunax controversial rehiring of his Home
Secretary we'll ask would a braver man
have left the whaler on the back benches
the NHS finally gets tough on the
extremist trans Lobby so are you finally
moving into a new era of Common Sense
trans advice
and just 50 days after the death of the
queen Harry reveals the title of his
much anticipated Memoir but is it tying
the monarchy through the book at the
increasingly disruptive place
live from London this is his Morgan
uncensored with Emily Sheffield and
Douglas Murray
from London and welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensored myself and Douglas Murray are
for the last time filling in for peers
before he returns from his Sun lounger
so it's been a pivotal few days in
British politics with the livelihoods of
millions of you at home set to be
impacted hopefully for the better by the
changes of this week yet even in this
most serious of times the dreaded
identity politics has had to infest its
mainstream namesake first up was the
controversy over whether former comedian
and future labor MP and present
attention seeker Eddie Izzard could
stand
while the possibility of of Israel
standing on an all-female shortlist
seemed to flummox labor leader Kirsten
conservative MP for Ashfield Lee
Anderson wasn't exactly on the fence
I want to be honest now controversial
um as always if he does get elected and
I'm still here I shouldn't be following
him into the toilets
ignoring the slightly troubling question
as to why Mr Anderson would want to
follow anyone at all into the toilets
I'm bewildered that putting a man onto
an all-woman's shortlist is even Up For
Debate it's not much better across the
pond where I spend most of my time these
days one prominent American broadcaster
decided to consider our new prime
minister this week's prime minister
solely through his race
you hear a lot of the people saying oh
you you they're taking over there you
you know now the Indians are going to
take over Great Britain and and what's
next and what and I and I I always find
myself going
so what
that's the fantastically ignorant Trevor
Noah there bringing in to disrepute all
decent men with two first names
klausovitz wrote that war is politics by
other means but in 2022 identity
politics has become War by other means a
way of eliminating dissent and forcing
entire continents to think in exactly
the same way but Putin the economy Mass
migration our times and our troubles are
too important for us to get distracted
by pronouns critical race Theory or even
the great enormous wisdom of Meghan
Markle
but first number 10 is given its full
backing to swella bravaman insisting she
maintains strong relationships with the
security services that despite MPS from
all sides raising concerns about the
home secretary's reappointment six days
six days after being forced out
following a misdirected email last night
on this very show former Tory chairman
Jake Berry said Braverman committed
multiple breaches of the ministerial
code listen to this
from my own knowledge there were
multiple breaches of the ministerial
code in fact multiple multiple beaches
of the ministerial code it was sent from
a private email address to another
Member of Parliament she then sought to
copy of that individual's wife and
accidentally sent it to a staffer in
Parliament to me that seems a really
serious breach especially when it was
documents relating to cyber security as
I believe
to discuss whether swaler is going to
prove to be the new PM's first big
Troublemaker Let's cross the former
Boris backer narishi convert
conservative MP Justin Tomlinson
good evening thank you Justin for
joining us
um let's just start with the question of
of suela bravaman
um is she the prime minister's first
liability kirst armor and the labor
party seem to think this is the great
weakness of the PM
well I mean the the opposition don't
like uh so well because she is a strong
Home Secretary who understands the need
to crack down on crime be tough with our
control of our borders and as we saw
today we've now reached three quarters
of our 20 000 extra police officers
targets and they're desperate for us not
to be on the front foot on Law and Order
issues which is something that they lost
a long time ago trust within their own
voters look she made an error she made
an error of a judgment but unlike many
many politicians she put her hand up she
took responsibility and she returned to
the back benches
can you imagine any other job still be
there on the back benches with the likes
of you okay can you imagine a new news
thanks Justin but look can you imagine
any other job in say the private sector
where you had to leave your job were
fired or resigned and then got
reappointed a week later because you
said sorry I I did indeed do all this
stuff wrong
well look as I said she she took
responsibility for her error of judgment
uh she she paid the price because she
returned to the back benches we have a
new prime minister and yes people make
mistakes private sector public sector we
all make mistakes but she is the best
person to be the Home Secretary the
Prime Minister will have no doubt had
conversations with her and I trust his
judgment on this but
but judgment
speech to everybody outside number 10
was to restore integrity
and then hours later he brings back a
Home Secretary who had only just been
removed for breaking the ministerial
code now she'd only been out of the job
having resigned over that for six days
now one understands there might have
been a bit of backroom dealing because
she was one of the right supporters
supporters on the right of the party
that threw her weight behind Rishi in
quite a surprise move actually but do
you think there's any chance he's
considering this has all turned out to
be bit too much of a headache
no I mean he would have looked at what
had happened I think the fact that she
it is dominating the headlines surely
this is not what Rishi planned one
assumes he's hoping that he can he can
Barrel his way out of this but I don't
see this as a great start to his to to
his tenure in number 10.
yeah well you're going to get opposition
MPS who don't like strong characters in
politics and Zoella has that in bucket
loads because she's not afraid to take
uh a strong
positions a lot of feathers within the
conservative party
no I think she's well respected among
amongst the conservative party and she
was an obvious choice when she was first
selected to be the Home Secretary and
continues to have the support so why do
you think Mary landed landed her in it
last night
well uh you know Jake's now got the
freedom of uh the back benches but I
don't remember him calling that out
whilst he was serving as party chairman
look she made an error of judgment
nobody's denying that least of all her
she put her hands up she took
responsibility too many politicians
don't they hide away from responsibility
she took that okay
it was only when the evidence was put in
front of her that that she agreed to it
but I mean I think we can all agree she
was having a fight with Liz truss of
immigration for sure Justin we've only
got a few seconds tell us uh you're on
the your third leader this year we've
got third prime minister this year the
conservative party is way behind in the
polls if you would have an election
today you'd be crushed by the labor
party uh do you think your party can
actually do anything to come back from
this state it's in
well yeah the opinion polls are
certainly character building you can't
you can't ignore those when you're at uh
you ultimately have to have an election
every five years and actually that's why
I had to agonize over the decision who
to support in this leadership contest I
was a friend of Boris I supported him I
admired his ability to reach across
traditional political uh divides but the
country needs calm and stability and
there were too many potential
distractions uh with Boris and what
Rishi was able to do was unite the party
and it didn't matter whether you were
one nation ERG remainer or a lever he
had his disposable the majority of
colleagues supporting him which meant he
could then select a cabinet of best
talents experience people who can
deliver quick tangible positive
difference to people with uh Financial
sustainability underlying all of our
decisions and this matters to the public
it's their mortgages it's their pensions
we get these things right we're back in
a fighting chance for that unprecedented
fifth term there's a big if there but
thank you very much Justin for joining
us uh joining us now in the studio is
former advisor to Boris Johnson Oscar
redrup and talk TV contributor Marina
Perkins thanks so much for joining us
first of all um Oscar what do you make
of that the party's unbelievably behind
in the polls uh it would be crushed if
there was an election today
um is there any way back for the party
that you've worked for uh well it's
actually really interesting when you
watch an MP they're having to take a
line on an issue that is very
contentious and almost potentially not
quite believing it himself or not quite
knowing it's going to hold uh the party
does have a very that's a partly a
hangover from Boris Johnson where they
went to they were sent out to defend all
these decisions only to almost as they
went on air I mean what one one can
sympathize that some of them are feeling
a bit nervous about defending defending
their prime minister I do understand
that um sorry Anne with Liz Trump but
you do have to measure cut through and
this is really interesting issue that
and this issue is a really good example
of that where yes we're talking about it
in the media and opposition mpsr maybe
even some back bench story MPS are but
ultimately like are people down the pubs
and bars talking about these texts that
went out by a Home Secretary I'm not
sure they are yeah
she is so in touch with what uh the
conservative party view as you know the
key home office issues on policies and
immigration party but in two years time
they've got to go to the country and
um I would hold that that video from the
conservative uh conference when she
talked was sort of utter Glee on her
face of her dream
of sending refugees to Rwanda which aim
is a completely failed policy but I
think that won't lie very comfortably
with a lot of Centrist voters who may
swing either way to labor or
conservative Marina what are your
thoughts on this my thoughts that any
credibility that Rishi sunak had went up
in smoke the moment that he appointed
her into the cabinet you can have you
might say that but he's actually ahead
in the polls of kirst armor today his
party is behind he is ahead he's on 38
he's kissed Thomas on 37. I think that's
just because there's been some positive
movement after the whole Fiasco that
we've seized
you've just said he's lost his
credibility clearly with the voters
according to that Polly hasn't lost his
credibility at all I think it is one
it's one pole and I think everyone see
what he's done here is an ERG pandering
move let's be honest compassion of the
ERG this was of Voters
worrying I think this is worrying for
kirst armor uh I don't think it is and
actually I think you know what leaves
leaves swell are in post let her have
more breaches because she's known as
leaky sue for goodness sake how is this
person has been allowed so you're not
convinced that mitmi 5 training she's
about to get is going to help us late in
the day after that yeah I mean if you've
got you've got a Home Secretary uh who
has to be trained whilst in post not to
breach security protocols and has to
have like a a learner program with MI5
it's not ideal is it experience Douglas
but not on your home secretary not
within the government I think that's a
bit so far I I there are some points
though actually have to agree with but
what I would say is labor don't want to
fall in the Trap of forgetting about the
issues of the day and falling into kind
of just trying to remove secretary's
estate and not actually addressing the
cost of living crisis and issues that do
deeply matter to people that's where
that's that's what you see next very
very very narrow I think route to
Victory if you just keep because he's
every leader needs a kind of gust of
wind behind them Boris was brexit and
his is the financial crisis that we're
currently well he is competent of course
you worked with with Boris Johnson
perhaps then I can ask you the uh
inevitable question have we actually
seen the last of him
I think I got asked this last week and I
kind of thought yes and then over the
weekend obviously that turned out
potentially not to be the case look I
think with Boris what I he and I really
genuinely believe this the guy's
complicated he has he is a complex
person he has faults but what he did uh
in terms of the Ukraine Russia situation
I think if a peaceful resolution is
found in time will be remembered in
history for decades to come I think what
we're hearing I saw a few stories that
he's planning on taking a job on the
international stage in you know
independently raising money for them
from Ukraine over egg this thing for for
what he did for Ukraine right don't
forget that for years both Boris Johnson
and previous conservative governments
denied any Aid to Ukraine because they
didn't want to ruffle Putin's feathers
and now he's been painted to some sort
of hero for what doing or any other sane
yeah I do I don't think that's
completely Fair because we actually
trained a lot of their army far faster
than anyone else in the EU did and we've
sent weapons in Far Far and remember
that and remember
the Germans wouldn't even allow British
planes to fly over German territory down
the ukrainians so if you talk about sane
governments you've got to remember that
there are a lot of insane governments by
your standard so we are now one of those
but he does also just really quickly he
does actually want like you forget again
you know there were you know millions of
people who votes conservative who've
never voted conservative before and I
think that ultimately he will just want
what's best for those communities and if
that's trusting you know the time moving
forward to Rishi sunak in terms of
leading us for a very difficult
financial situation George Johnson cares
about communities of course I mean
that's I mean ultimately the man who
goes on holidays
something that's already dominating
we've had a lot on immigration and
swallow brought them and dominating our
attention today but we've got Prince
Harry's we've seen for the first time
the cover of his book his autobiography
which is landing in January we now know
uh it was going to land next summer so
it does look like he's managed to
persuade his Publishers to move it
forward to January because as anyone who
works in publishing knows you don't
publish big books in January so you do
publish them just before the coronation
yes but the coronation is not is is much
later so I'm assuming there's there's
been a bit of touring and throwing there
but you've seen the type you've there it
is on it's it's entitled despair now
I would have thought given the
controversy recently the Queen's death
of falling out with his family there was
a moment that there was a moment at that
funeral where you saw them all coming
together for a while this is absolutely
going to throw the throw any kind of
mutual coming together again out the
window what's your thoughts why has he
done it well I I I feel really again I
feel really in a strange place with this
because if it's his truth and it's it
comes from him and he really wanted to
do this then I think there should be a
space in the world for him for that to
allowed to happen my suspicion is 36
million pounds he was paid for it had
nothing to do with him wanting to know
that much was that much well apparently
right okay let's change a little bit no
but my point is if we've got such a
problem with his voicing his views
voicing his experience no I
agreements he did have right I get I
know it Life's a privilege and I'm no
royalist but he also suffered with stuff
he also suffered with the fact that his
family didn't support him with his his
father giving him terrible advice with
regards to the media and saying well I
had to deal with it so you're gonna have
to deal with it my parents
Mourinho and Oscar thank you very much
I've got to say Oscar you can't come
back again because you use the phrase
his truth
that is that is the most that's the only
triggering thing you can say to me so if
we have your truth my truth there's no
truth anyway
still to come tonight first reviews of
Prince Harry's books before 9pm and has
the NHS finally transition to a senseful
position on what some people describe as
teenager gender confusion we're back in
through
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
NHS England has unveiled new guidance
for youngsters distressed about their
gender doctors should now carefully
explore all underlying health problems
being mindful that this may be a
transient phase
but extremists continue to intimidate
anyone who disagrees with them just this
week Cambridge University had to
apologize to students for inviting Helen
Joyce who believes that one's sex cannot
be changed
luckily Helen Joyce won't be silenced
and she's with us now alongside Ollie
London who de-transitions and now lives
as a man again good evening both of you
thank you so much for coming on the show
now Ollie I wanted to talk to you first
you were very keen to come on tonight
and tell us a bit about your story
you transition to a woman and now you're
back as a man what led that decision did
you feel forced into it just just give
us a little bit of detail um so my whole
life I was actually very um unhappy with
the way I looked so it actually started
out as me wanting to change wanting to
look more perfect more beautiful so I
kind of went on this Quest since 2013 to
undergo surgery to try and Achieve
Perfection and I've kind of realized
that Perfection is not attainable so do
you think that was more sort of body
dysmorphia I think so I've come to
realize now I've had so many surgeries
about 32 actual plastic surgeries in
total
um as you can see I've got so many scars
kind of all over my face so I feel like
that's how it started off and then I got
to a point earlier this year where I
still haven't achieved happiness so I
thought maybe I should be a trans woman
maybe that's why I'm unhappy so you know
I was trans for six months you know I
had the facial feminization surgery I
had 11 procedures I had the hair
extensions and I just realized you know
it just wasn't wasn't me it wasn't who I
was inside were you taking any advice
from anyone were you were you seeking
medical help psychiatric help what kind
of advice were you being offered at the
time it was more seeing things online
you know I'm a social media person so
I'm always using Tick Tock pictures here
of you as a woman so how long ago was
that was that quite recently that was
actually at London Fashion Week so that
was literally a month ago so kind of a
drastic change
um but I'm always kind of changing my
looks I'm always kind of changing up but
yeah I kind of saw on social media you
know people constantly changing their
identities and I thought you know why
not let me try it let me see if it's for
me but even as a trans woman I was very
respectful for women I would never use
women's restrooms or changing rooms I
never wanted women to feel threatened by
me I was just kind of I guess I was
having an identity crisis or gender
dysphoria which a lot of kids have these
days so I just want to speak up to try
and raise awareness that you know kids
should not be transitioning well Helen
this comes into something that you wrote
about in your book
um I mean there's been this whole
question in recently it's about
suggestibility which you address and
have a lot of thoughts on but also this
question of whether people who feel in
some way uncomfortable in their bodies
or not perfect is all he said and being
sort of pushed down this road is saying
well if you're a teenager and you're
uncomfortable in your body instead of
being just a teenager and maybe you're
actually in the wrong sex I mean we know
all people are quite uh easy to
influence in this sort of way like
diseases get shaped in doctors waiting
rooms between the doctor and the patient
and then the media play a part in that
and in the last 10 years or so I would
say social media has come in to make a
big big difference there so yeah I mean
I don't I think it's inarguable that
things like anorexia or social
contagions and I think we're seeing a
social contagion now with gender
dysphoria that kids who would never have
thought to themselves that there was any
question that they could change sex I
mean that's not actually possible but
you know get that idea into their heads
they pick that idea up online then they
present it to doctors who are thinking
about an old-fashioned way to look at
this that there are a tiny number of
people who have this thing called gender
dysphoria they haven't updated their
thinking for modern times and social
media they're diagnosing those kids and
they're putting them down a pathway that
it's hard to get off now we mentioned
earlier what happened with you at
Cambridge University this week maybe
tell us a little bit about this because
it sort of seems surprising to me of all
the people who sort of trying to depict
of some mad right-wing Maniac Nutter I
don't think of you as being number one
on the list almost everybody I know I'd
put on the list ahead of you so how come
how come you've become uninvitable at
Cambridge University I mean all I can
say is I think the world has gone mad I
mean it all I'd all I do is say there
are two Sexes and you can't change sex
in some situations that matters
especially for women that's it that's my
three beliefs they're not even beliefs
they're just facts but it turns out
they're inconvenient facts for people
who think about the world through
identities and who like to think about
everything is changeable everything is
mutable you know it's this modern sort
of queer Theory influenced way of
thinking about identity that all
boundaries are fluid and that everything
that is fixed is bad and constraining
and that we have to try and overturn
everything so I guess that you know
somebody who just says very boringly
like mums are very boring people who say
to you you know pack an umbrella do you
know where you're going and by the way
sorry you can't have everything you want
in life uh you know that didn't go down
very well I just wanted because I wanted
the pair of you to talk about this in a
way you talk about the reasons why
people are confusing sex with gender
identity and one of them I thought was
very interesting was socialized
socialization and because of you having
lots of wanting to be more beautiful you
say that being being a woman is now
because is considered by say the trans
Community some members of the trans
community that that's about how we
behave but that's not true we're talking
about a biological a biological
difference between us
um so but I think it's interesting that
you pick up on the beautiful beautifying
of us and that's exactly what you were
trying to do and confusing that maybe
with wanting to change sex is is that
something you know I definitely feel I
had gender dysphoria and I definitely
think you know when we look at
television shows I mean you have some
really shocking things like on Channel 4
when they had the other day the trans
person ripping all their clothes off
playing a piano with their penis I mean
that is just beyond shocking and you
know unfortunately when women tried to
speak out and say you know this is not
good for our kids they get canceled they
get silenced just like JK Rowling
and you know I think it's wrong and I
think there are so many people out there
trying to push these ideas on young
people and I think I was one of those
people influenced by that you know I was
just chasing Perfection but I thought
you know maybe I'm trapped because
everybody else is saying oh you can
change this you can change that I
understand biology and I also agree with
Helen you know you can't change biology
but I think with me it's more trying to
change my looks let me make an
alteration by the way how long as we
start to wrap up
um in the states the trans debate is
nowhere near as advanced as it is here
in the UK and the thing that is missing
there and what we seem to have here is
left-wing women among others speaking up
gay women straight women and that seems
to be changing the debate uh you're
obviously a part of this but do you
agree I mean there's a there's a shift
going on yes I think that in America
it's sadly become a totally polarized
issue that if you're a Democrat you have
to believe that people can change sex
and that gender identity overwrites sex
and if you're a republican you can be
against it but then there's a bunch of
other things that you believe that a lot
of women would find quite on congenial
and so each side sort of looks at the
other side and says you know look at the
Mad things they believe look what
they'll do to us whereas here I think
there are much more cross-party
allegiances and much more cross-cutting
sort of approaches to it and much more
rationalist and focused on children as
well that's the important thing we're
misleading children I mean Ollie's a
grown-up if he wants to do these things
to himself that's one thing but leading
a child's down that path children
believe what adults tell them but also I
think the big thing that we're
discussing is that this this it needs to
be discussed it needs to be debated
without being shouted down of course
there are differences of opinions there
are members of the trans Community who
want to bring their issues to the light
but we should be able to discuss it as
adults yeah and not and not be silenced
on either side including at universities
and if you can't talk about this
universities work could you nowhere
apparently thank you so much for both
coming on the show tonight we really
appreciate it still to come spare part
and reveals the title of his upcoming
memoir
and after Trevor Noah implied we are a
nation of racists we'll discuss whether
he is right back in three
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back it hasn't been the best of
weeks for late night American talk show
hosts but Trevor Noah very much
delivered a hold my beer moment to James
Corden last night just take a look at
this
watching the story of Rishi sunak
becoming England's first prime minister
of color of Indian descent of all of
these things and then seeing the
backlash is one of the more telling
um it's just one of the more telling
things about how people view the role
that they or their people have played in
in history and what I mean by that is
this you hear a lot of the people saying
oh you you they're taking over there you
know now the Indians are going to take
over Great Britain and and what's next
and what and I and I I always find
myself going
so what
what
what's the backlash exactly who's seen
the backlash there seems to be an
entirely imaginary thing it's like this
is just happening in Trevor Noah's head
I don't know if I missed something my I
think not now joining us from Alabama to
discuss Noah's bizarre rant is American
political commentator C.J Pearson
thanks for having me it's great to have
you with us what did you make of this uh
CJ I mean it it just strikes me as
something from a different planet
yeah but it's also a broken record
unfortunately we have to deal with that
here in America every single day of
people like Trevor Noah looking to blame
racism on every single thing in the
world you know they call our country
fundamentally racist and I guess now you
guys are getting the same treatment but
notice in that segment he didn't point
out the people that are actually
attacking the new prime minister because
they're not from the conservative party
so I wonder who those people must be no
but apparently it this all came from one
caller calling into a popular radio show
here I mean that there has been Rishi
sunak's coronation as our as our prime
minister has been welcomed by everybody
including by by President Biden who who
called him Rashad Sanuk or something uh
but yeah anyway apart from that everyone
seems to have welcomed it warmly
to paint the UK as having a problem with
us having
um a prime minister of of with with
Indian parents
because he doesn't possess the death to
talk about real issues isn't possessed
enough to talk about global inflation it
doesn't possess the deaf to talk about
UK politics or anything like that but
what he can do is make everyone out to
be some racist Boogeyman this is exactly
what the left does every single day
where there isn't a issue or with race
at all they make it to be as if it's
something that you should consume
yourself with every single day people
are championing uh the new prime
minister of UK and for good reason it's
a huge milestone but let's also point
out the historical fact that every every
single modern PM that we've had that's
been a female has been from the
conservative party and now the first
Indian English uh man who is a British
PM from the conservative party where's
labor at on that I don't see him at all
well one of the other interesting things
about this CJ is the fact that all this
has this weird American lens put over it
I mean you know every country has its
own historical problems every country
has its own issues but this is like
watching a well first of all Trevor
knows who grew up in South Africa so
maybe he sort of sees some of this
through the lens of apartheid but he
then transport transfers that onto
America and there from that transfers
that onto the UK and it seems to be just
it just doesn't work and the most
remarkable thing about about uh about
our prime minister is the fact that race
and religion weren't an issue at any
stage in the campaign for anyone nobody
said he he should get the job because of
his race or his his religion they said
he should get the job because they
thought he was the best person for the
job
yeah you know and what's what's most
exhausting about the narrative that
you're hearing from Trevor and this is
plagued America for far too long is this
Perpetual need to be a victim and to see
victimhood in every single story this is
a moment of Triumph This is a moment of
something that you would think Trevor
know would be heralding but instead he's
trying to point out racism simply where
it isn't and you have to wonder why is
there that incessant need for them to
have racism in a society why is there
this incessant need for them to have
someone be a victim it just goes to show
that the only thing they know how to do
is divide and conquer they seek to do
that through race religion and so much
more and yet they blame conservatives
for doing just that but they do it every
single day but I think is it not true to
say there are still there are still
problems with race and we we have still
some issues here in Britain and you
still definitely have some issues in
America and these problems exist around
the world but it seems a like a sort of
cry wolf situation here where why wasn't
he why wasn't he celebrating how how
enthusiastic we were with our new prime
minister wouldn't get him the ratings
that's why well I I think it's just made
him look rather stupid and ill-informed
myself
yeah you're completely right as a person
of color I completely agree with you but
the thing about race here is if you call
everything racist no one's going to
believe you when something actually is
racist and that's the thing that these
people don't
understanding real issues
exactly that exactly this is a moment to
be celebrated uh and not shamed and it's
unfortunate Trevor decided to ring on
what otherwise is a very historic moment
uh in the UK right now and what about in
America CJ how's this gone down is is
Trevor Noah's ratings and the late night
shows gonna go up or down on the basis
of this
well notice Trevor Noah is leaving the
Late Night show so I guess that says
everything uh that needs to be said
about his incredible career here he can
go out on a sour note
thanks CJ exactly that thanks so much
thank you
well in Britain we undoubtedly do have
problems a report released today
revealed the government is spending 5.6
million pounds a day housing Asylum
Seekers that could pay for 16 000
hospital beds of the 38 000 illegal
immigrants crossing the channel this
year over 10 000 Albanian men despite no
conflict in the Balkans for over 25
years have we lost control
joining us now chair of Migrant watch
Alf Mehmet and Steve Valdez Simmons
Refugee and migrant rights program
director at Amnesty International
welcome thank you so much thanks for
being here thank you so much for being
um with us today
um
tell me what do you get a sense that the
government has actually got a plan to a
stem to stop the tide of little boats
coming over and also once they're here
it seems that the centers that they're
used for processing are being
overwhelmed and visas are being stuck in
the system we've got 120 I've been doing
110 and 120 000 visas which is waiting
to be processed meaning that many
desperate refugees are being left
sitting in hotels when they could be
building new lives here including ten
thousand
refugees that we invited from
Afghanistan Alf what's your opinion
um
we're in a mess
unquestionably if we're in a total mess
the system is overwhelmed the resources
available to deal with those coming are
totally inadequate and frankly up until
now
I think we haven't had a clue as to how
to stop
those coming across the channel from
from streaming across in ever greater
numbers
actually is finally someone who may well
be able to get a grip and deal with it
that is back it up sorry back it up with
what proof well that's what that's a
feeling that's not a factor approval
having having observed home secretaries
having worked for many of them as an
immigration officer what I hear from her
is absolutely spot on and guess what
this is why
this is why what have you heard from her
hold on this is why everyone is turning
against her now because labor is frankly
afraid that she's actually going to get
it done I'd like to know how she's going
to get it done I have not heard a
cohesive ban from the government at all
she's she's going to get it done a by
talking to the French which is an old
thing second Lee she's going to hold on
actually part of the group thirdly she's
someone that who's going to resign from
the echr fourthly she's actually going
to pursue the Rwanda arrangement
and finally she's actually going to
remove those young and dusted you've got
we didn't even get a flight off the
ground did we we spent 160 million and
anyway you can only take 200 people
we're waiting for the courts I think
we'll see that will be done sorry sorry
what's a real plan what is a real plan
this government has not come up with a
real plan and all that it has allowed is
an absolute and absolute mess in the
immigration office which is costing the
taxpayer 6.5 million a day in hotels so
why don't they take some of that money
and spend it on staff for the
immigration system and get these people
through the system and either they're
going to be asked to leave the country
and we have to deport them because
they're not they're not being approved
or they can get out and make a life here
we have got so many jobs waiting to be
filled let's be clear on the fundamental
reason why this has happened we have
home office policy introduced by the
previous Home Secretary Patel but
pursued still by swella Braverman that
has put a stop on actually processing
claims that's why only four percent of
claims in the whole of 2021 even now
towards the end of this you just clarify
for me what do you mean they they
stopped it what what what what what did
they bring in that stopped it it sounds
to me more like it's just sort of chaos
no they brought in rules to declare all
of them if they wished inadmissible
on the basis that somehow they will
persuade other countries to receive
people rather than take our
responsibilities with the claims that we
get there are a couple of different
problems though here aren't there
there's the issue of the backlog and
then there's the issue of the incoming
flow you're from Amnesty International
uh what's your plan for stopping the
illegal boats
um if you want to stop people coming by
unauthorized means the only way that you
can do that is to provide authorized
means for people who need to make those
Journeys and we make no such routes
available there are no routes for legal
Asylum Seekers absolutely none to claim
asylum in this country you must
physically be here our immigration rules
make absolutely plain there is no visa
for anyone to come to this country to
seek Asylum so if you wish to seek a
sign what about the Afghan Asylum
Seekers
um if you're seeking Asylum you have to
get here you may be fortunate to come
within a resettlement program so there
is there are ways hang on there are ways
well that was a resettlement he said
that there weren't any ways not to get
through legally not not for anyone to
seek Asylum here you have to be picked
out fortunately
under a resettlement program which we
have one for Afghanistan and we do have
a Visa system for ukrainians that's it
if you are fleeing persecution anywhere
else or you are just hopelessly at risk
from Afghanistan and you are not being
picked and have no information about it
at all so this is all that why why we
got the situation among other things of
ten thousand young Albanian men uh
fleeing the hell hole of France why has
that happened absolutely the hell hole
of France if you've put your finger on
it the fact is that all those who are
coming across the channel have come from
a safe country and very often have been
through safe countries and very often
something like 40 of them have already
applied and been rejected in other
countries but the fact is you can't
simply dismiss those who've come from
from Afghanistan those who've come from
Hong Kong those who've come from Ukraine
and it's what's Steve says is right we
shouldn't really have any Asylum
grantees here who haven't crossed the
channel and the fact is that there are
thousands who have been granted Asylum
if you were to set up a system a process
whereby people are applying overseas it
would be overwhelmed within days what do
we do about the fact that this country
now has an absolutely historic number of
people crossing the channel this wasn't
the case even a few years ago a few
years ago I think with 20 people came
across the channel uh why is this
situation happen and how on Earth can it
be well
let's be clear we do not have an
historic number of people who have
crossed the channel when was there a
year when there was more in 2000 yeah
2000s more people crossed the channel
by small boats you didn't see them
Crossing but they crossed these were
people who jumped into Lorry back
lorries
you're sure that that was that was more
than there are
from the Balkans there were in the early
2000s more coming over but they were
coming over legally they were not
crossing the channel in small boats they
were not coming in the backs of lorries
they were making their way legally and
they were allowed to stay what strikes
me about this is the fact that we
basically got a system where we do
actually have a legal system where you
can apply for Asylum but we've now also
got a system where a first person across
the channel in a boat gets to come in
and stay and will never be returned
whatever and that's the reason why they
will continue to come and have a greater
numbers yeah and I have to say a
thousand this year 28
000 last year 8 000 the year before
we're talking about it yeah
I have to say I wish I had your
confidence that because the Home
Secretary says I have heard this from so
many home secretaries over recent years
I have no faith at all anyway next
tonight what a way to start 2023 Prince
Harry's Memoir is out 10 days into the
new year should every one of us
best-selling authors be quaking in our
boobs we'll find out next
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back
spare us all we now know Prince Harry's
Memoir will be published on January the
10th and will feature a brooding picture
of him on the front and we'll be
entitled spare now I just want to read
you a little quote uh that's coming uh
sort of description by Harry about the
book I've worn many hats over the years
both literally and figuratively
figuratively excuse me
um My Hope Is that in telling my story
the highs and lows the mistakes the
Lessons Learned I can help show that no
matter where we come from we have more
in common than we think now that's a
perfectly nice sentiment a bit gooey a
bit American for British audience but a
very nice sentiment I I can't you know
you can't you can't I don't know yeah I
know but you wouldn't I feel kind of
diabetic after that yes
this is a book which he has been
reportedly paid for 36 million now we
don't know if that's true that's just a
reported figure in Hello magazine I
suspect it's slightly exaggerated but we
do know it's been a very Hefty sum as
he's already said he's donating 1.2
million pounds of it to go to charity
now and the rest to go into his pocket
and if you know anything about
Publishers they will not have agreed to
this book just being about Harry telling
his now just wait here here's truth
um I know you're squirming and feeling a
bit sick as I said that so we know there
are going to be elements of this book
that are going to prove highly
controversial for the royal family now
I've always been a big defender of Harry
and Megan I am slightly running out of
steam so I just we've got Diggy I'm
surprised you've lasted this long
joining us now to discuss this literary
event of the century we have talk TV
contributor Paula Roan Adrian and Royal
author Dickie Arbiter thanks so much to
you both for joining us first of all
with you Dicky I mean this is this is
now primed to come out just before the
coronation what are the effects of that
what are the effects of it coming out
full stop uh I think it's a great
mistake he's just he's doing what his
dad did in 94. Jonathan dim will be
cooperating he's doing what his mum did
with Andrew Morton in 1992. why is he
bringing out a book he's obviously got a
lot on his chest that he wants to get
off
um unfortunately we saw part one with
the Oprah interview My Truth uh in which
the queen late Queen came out with that
wonderful one-liner Recollections may
vary and I think we'll find a lot in
this book where Recollections may vary I
think Dickie is interesting that you
bring up the fact that he's not the
first member of the royal family to um
or give an interview as you say that
that causes a lot of problem and I and I
I am concerned as someone who has
defended them in the past they they get
a they get a a very large degree of
hostility
um about anything they do but having
Harry must have seen the effect of
um his actions so far the Opera Oprah
interview I am slightly staggered after
the after the funeral where you saw it
it's very painful when families are
ripped apart and brothers are not
talking to each other do you think this
book was already in the process do you
think he might be regretting this he
might well be regretting it but uh it's
too late there were there was talk there
was speculation that he was asking for
changes now we heard uh how true it is
we don't know that he had signed off on
the book in summer Publishers are very
quick to press the button to run the
printing presses to get the book out in
the Autumn uh did he make the changes we
don't know what's he doing with the
money well we know that a million uh
pounds is going to send to Bali 300
000 pounds is going to uh Wellness uh
organization Vicky we're just going to
get Paula in here um
what's your opinion how explosive do you
think this book is going to be or we're
already we're we're doing exactly what
the Publishers want us to do which is
getting frightfully riled up before
we've even read it and publicity too
exactly and really and truthfully what
is it that we don't know already
and I suspect that that's what's going
to happen I suspect we're going to get
this book
which will be interesting we will hear
Harry's voice in the way no doubt he
wants us to but ultimately in terms of
the shock Factor I'm just not sure we're
there anymore I I think you know what
more have we got we've had racism we've
had mental health we have had Oprah
we've we've had Oprah we have had the
sad destruction of a loving family you
know we've had it where else are we
gonna go with this well here's the thing
though in my experience a publisher does
not pay 36 million uh dollars uh to get
a reheated stuff they've had before they
will be saying you've got to give us
more they will stop pound the flesh
that's my concern is even if it's the
odd paragraph in there yeah and it
really thousands of words could be a lot
more sort of self-help my truth garble
but it only takes four paragraphs saying
something about entirely Pleasant about
his father his upbringing yeah the queen
consort Yeah but whether there's any
truth in it that remains to be seen well
and and you know we've had we've had
numerous Bible sheets three four of King
Charles look we're not going to hear
anything new we don't need to be excited
I'm afraid I've got to break in that's
it from us peers are we making as much
anticipated return on Monday
and whatever you're up to make sure that
it's uncensored
have a good night good night
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]